good evening markets soared across
Europe today while the Euro hit a
five-month high after the first round of
the French election investors relieved
that the centrist emmanuel macron made
the final round and that voters haven't
been left with two Euroskeptic
candidates well here the footsie 100
enjoyed its biggest one-day gain since
last September although in percentage
terms it only did half as well as the
cat current in France the german dax
rose to a record high while in italy the
mid put on nearly five percent our
senior correspondent Michelle Clifford
is live in Paris irish old in mock it
seemed pretty confident that macarons
gonna win the second round he still
would have beat marine lepen though
hasn't he he has but all the predictions
are good certainly all the way through
the campaign the polls were saying and
saying again last night that if marine
lepen and emmanuel macron went through
to the second round that he would be two
hands down the predictions now are and
that he'd get 60-plus percent so feeling
confident although mr. macron today was
back at his party headquarters on march
headquarters he was taking nothing for
granted he said he can't be complacent
so he was galvanizing his base again
he's got this amazing grassroots body
that's working for him and they're going
to be going out there over the course of
the next two weeks you know trying to
win the voters from the candidates who
lost last night and many of those
candidates have fallen in behind makram
the momentum seems to be with him but
marine lepen is a formidable character
and a formidable candidate she hit the
campaign trail today she was pushing the
narrative that emmanuel macron is simply
francois hollande in another suit and
Hollande of course is a terribly
unpopular leader of France at the moment
and she was also pushing the narrative
that macron is weak particularly when it
comes to Islamic extremism extremism and
that is a narrative that does resonate
with the French electorate especially
because of the attack last week all
right thanks Michelle well aniston it's
k is a global economist at fidelity
international anna the polls got it
right for once big takeaway from this
yeah
a big relief for markets well firstly
because this the most disruptive market
outcome lepen vs shawn has been avoided
but also yes the polls were right and
that means that the second round where
McCrone is very likely to lead with a
comfortable twenty percent or so means
that the the terrorists cough Lapan of
the disruption in the European Union is
probably avoided yeah I think there's
something like six and a half million
voters who went for fee on or melon shin
or arm on the other defeated candidates
I mean marine lepen is going to have to
Hoover up all of those votes to stand a
chance isn't she most of the candidates
apart from Milan China actually have now
endorsed mikone so hopefully most of
them will vote for him but of course
there is still some uncertainty I think
it's too early to be relaxed and in fact
a lower turnout just as in the first
round a lot turnout could actually
favored lupan in the second row so why
is Macomb being seen as so
market-friendly I mean there are a lot
of reforms he I mean he wants to cut
corporate taxes for example but what are
the other real things that investors are
hoping to see from him he is prob
business perform his pro deregulation
and obviously he's also pro-eu and
that's one risk that has been dominating
the markets there is Corexit and read
elimination but the real question is how
much is going to implement and I think
it's very important of course that he
wins in the second round but as soon as
it happens the focus will shift to the
parliamentary election exactly and he's
probably not going to have way he's a
new party you won't have a party besok
behind him in Parliament so he's going
to have to work with the Republicans
with the Socialist Party how's that
gonna play out do you think yeah it's
very unlikely that his party will get a
majority although we don't know we will
see so he will have to have some sort of
cohabitation with the Republican so in
minority government or some sort of
arrangement with the socialist actually
there is a range of outcomes and we
don't know but the fact of the matter is
it's going to be quite difficult for him
to implement all the reform that he is
promising and of course marine lepen is
going to be you know the National Front
National could have 40 or so deputies in
the French parliament as well yeah
actually think the biggest risk is
actually a longer term the French
elections 2022 if mikone doesn't deliver
then the loop and we'll have a chance
again so the euros thrown an absolute
party today and biggest gain in five
months is back trading back to where it
was against the US dollar in November
last year we going to sit on the screen
there I mean is that a permanent shift
in sentiment do you think I think
obviously the growth story in the euro
area has been improving but markets have
been held back to some extent
particularly the urine fixed income by
this political uncertainty so this risk
premium is now getting priced out so
markets are doing well and the focus of
course is shifting to the ECB and the
view in the market has been that they
said we will not be able to move towards
normalizing policy until this risk is
out of the way and I don't think they
are likely to do anything big this month
this week in fact but as we move into
June into the second half of the year I
think that they will start changing
stance so well these big gains in French
banking stocks are in Credit Suisse
SocGen BMP Perry bar they were all up by
between eight and ten percent today yeah
this is just based on expectations that
finally this extraordinary accommodation
by the ECB is coming to an end they are
expected to lay out a tapering plant QE
tapering plan over the next few months
and also they've been some signals from
Draghi and other members of the ECB that
the might consider hiking the deposit
rate from the negative territory perhaps
back to zero and of course this is a
huge boost to banks